what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and I just watched the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
I just watched it I was sitting right
there I finished it put down my thoughts
on my phone about it and here I am so
it's very fresh for me
um sorry I'm a little bit sick I'm not
crying from the movie all although I did
it did actually make me cry not like saw
being sad but it's a it's a feel-good
holiday Christmas movie
that has some really touching Parts it
really does this is one of those
things going in where I think of like
Christmas specials holiday specials I
think of like the Grinch Jingle All The
Way Home Alone stuff like that you know
the movies that you kind of watch each
year because they make it feel like
Christmas it's like you know an
unofficial tradition or maybe official
in your family that that you might do
during the holidays so that's what I
thought this was going to be like and
that's pretty much what it was uh and I
really enjoyed it I actually really did
I didn't expect much coming in so let's
talk about one thing first before I talk
about some other things and all are kind
of important but the first thing is I
want to talk about what James Gunn said
he did say that this of course is MCU
Cannon which it is and he did say that
this happens after Thor 11 Thunder
but before Guardians of the Galaxy 3. so
it happens after Guardians 2 in-game all
of that stuff and I'm assuming this is
like right before Guardians 3. now no
spoilers in this this is going to be a
spoiler free review so don't worry about
that excuse me but
there are
big Parts in this that will affect the
MCU but they're very quick
and they're not the focus maybe kind of
one thing that's that's talked about at
the end that might it'll have a effect
on the guardians but not a huge effect
on the MCU as a whole there is one
really a big part
and it's definitely going to have some
big implications for the future of the
MCU and the future of the Guardians of
the Galaxy for sure in fact it was like
I mentioned it was everything's quick
that's kind of serious and it was so
quick
that I had to pause it when I was
watching it rewind it
and then put the subtitles on because I
was like
did I just hear that right
did they just say what I think they just
said and then subtitles confirmed it yes
and I was like that's kind of big
I was like that's that's that's really
big and they just kind of brush over it
now it's kind of a part it's kind of
like an unspoken part of the whole
entire special and you'll see what I
mean getting those spoilers but I was
like huh
that actually is kind of big that's
that's something so there are a few big
Parts there's some pretty
pretty good parts that are really quick
and you're just kind of like oh like
Cosmo the dog and
she was introduced
in the trailer so this isn't really a
spoiler if you've seen the trailers
which I hope you have
you know that's like a big deal
right but it's it's not such a big deal
on the Christmas special and I'm now I'm
I'm wondering like okay is Cosmo going
to be a part of Guardians of the Galaxy
will Cosmo be in Guardians of the Galaxy
3 right so there's little things like
that but there's this this one big part
where I'm like huh this is a
this is kind of important and they kind
of just say it and brush over it like
it's nothing I know they'll address it
in Guardians of the Galaxy 3. like I
know they will there was one part at the
end
keep in mind it's a Christmas movie
there are gifts that are exchanged and
there's this one part in relation to
Groot who is I like in this I really do
um where I was genuinely confused it
it's not like it has any big implication
or anything like that not even that it's
important but I was so confused and I
was just like wait a second huh I don't
I don't even understand but it's there
and it's kind of funny
now what to expect
like I mentioned this is a Christmas
holiday film it's not avengers endgame
and and it's not trying to be right so
don't don't go in there expecting it to
blow your mind to be game changing for
the MCU it it's kind of like werewolf by
night werewolf by night was a great
watch and the story was great and just
watching it was awesome
did it really affect the MCU probably
those specific events not really did it
affect a character that's going to be in
the MCU yes absolutely
that's what we have here these will
affect kind of the Guardians of the
Galaxy but that's not what it's about
it's a feel good
40 minute I think 40 40
5 42 minutes uh movie about the holidays
and about a family right because the
Guardians are family there's
there's some genuine touching moments in
this as you would expect from any
holiday Christmas film now I will say
I almost like kept a tally like a tab of
how many times I laughed out loud that
because it's classic Guardians humor
the only way I could really describe
this movie is it's a Christmas movie
with the Guardians of the Galaxy
it's like that's how you would describe
it their humor and it works perfectly
because I love the Guardians of the
Galaxy there's one of my favorite teams
in the MCU and
you know Christmas time makes you feel
good holiday season makes you feel good
and they touch on all of that right it's
funny it's light-hearted but it's also
very heartfelt at the same time very
touching it really is like I said I
actually did cry
at the very end you'll see why
not spoilers no spoilers can't put any
spoilers in this but you know it's it's
it's one of those movies that I think
now I'll watch every year I do I think
I'm gonna watch it every year now the
ending
is
cool
it's really cool
um
you know without saying anything it's
touching but it also
it tells you a story of how
some things came to be with quilt with
Star-Lord which I think is really really
cool it's kind of uh weird
it's not I'll just say it's not shot in
the same way that the rest of the the
film is shut
um that's all I'll say about that
because I don't want to give any
spoilers away for it but it it opens
with this kind of filming and you're
kind of confused at first but now I
understand why they did it and at the
end it ends with that as well and you're
just kind of like huh interesting that
they decided to do it I get why but the
story that it's actually telling is cool
it's artfelt
um and I enjoyed it I enjoyed pretty
much everything about this even Kevin
Bacon the story I mean truthfully what I
I think who I enjoyed the most was
mantis right because you've seen a lot
of the footage in the trailers that's
mantis and Drax go to earth right and
try to get Kevin Bacon for quill and
mantis Palm
it she's awesome
and I I love the chemistry between Drax
and mantis I love the chemistry between
her and quill and the rest of them even
like Karen Gillen nebula like she her
scenes like they're kind of quick
sometimes but I'm like dang like amazing
job I don't need a review the actors we
know they're all great at playing their
parts right everyone does amazing but
really the story and just the humor
comedy is really good it's that classic
Guardians of the Galaxy humor mixed in
with a good heartfelt holiday Christmas
Story
so it's really really cool I recommend
everybody watch it
I'm sure most people will really love
this and think it's really fun at the
least I've talked to a few people who've
already watched it and they're just kind
of like
well it's nothing special
and after watching it I'm like well sure
it it doesn't really it's not avengers
end game but you know what it's not
supposed to be so I'm super okay with
that I think it's really great I think
it's really just a fun feel good time
and I think it's exactly what James Gunn
and all of the cast and Kevin feige
wanted it to be it's cool it's really
fun it's a good ride and it's it's part
of my like Christmas
tradition untradition time where I I'm
gonna watch it each year just because
it's like oh hey we gotta watch the
Guardians of the Galaxy uh holiday
special so it comes out not too long
from now I want to know what everybody
thinks uh let me know what you think so
far from the trailers that you've seen
and let me know how excited you are for
it because I I truly I truly enjoyed it
this is
probably one of the better things to
come from phase four
as far as enjoyment as far as my
enjoyment goes it's uh it's definitely
one of the better things to come from
phase four so I'm excited for everybody
to watch it I'm excited to watch it
again maybe we'll do a watch party but
uh yeah so don't forget to subscribe so
you can tune in to that watch party and
of course all the other Marvel videos
and of course I will catch you all in
the next video thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
foreign